cientos de seguidores del opositor a la
china wang y detenidos desde la primera
hora de la mañana en toda rusia y el
frío extremo del invierno ni la
anunciada presencia policial frenaron
este sábado las multitudinarias
manifestaciones a favor de la libertad
de navalny convocadas en decenas de
ciudades de todo el país en el oriente
ruso estas manifestaciones ya
desembocaron en cientos de detenciones y
enfrentamientos con la policía en
jabárovsk una de las primeras ciudades
en sumarse a las convocatorias unos 300
manifestantes exigieron la liberación
del opositor al tiempo que protestaron
por la crítica realidad en la que viven
si los precios están subiendo todo está
subiendo mira cómo están viviendo las
regiones y como moscú mira cómo viven
allí al otro lado de los urales y luego
ven aquí y mira como la gente vive en
los pueblos la televisión dice una cosa
pero luego echa un vistazo a tu
alrededor
en moscú donde está convocada la más
grande de las marchas se registraron por
lo menos 100 arrestos antes del inicio
de las mismas
alexéi navalni fue arrestado el pasado
domingo después de aterrizar en rusia
haberse recuperado en alemania- del
envenenamiento con un agente tóxico
soviético el pasado agosto podría
enfrentar hasta tres años y medio de
prisión por supuestamente haber
incumplido las condiciones de una pena
dictada en 2014 tras su arresto estará
en prisión al menos hasta el 15 de
febrero
putin ha negado tajantemente las
acusaciones que apuntan a su vinculación
con el envenenamiento de su principal
opositor